in my quest to re-read attack on titan
now that it's finished to see how it all
wraps together and witness the whole
series once more in all of its glory
i went back through the very beginning
of the series including the fall of
shiganshina and
primarily the battle for tross district
arc for the first time in over seven
years
since the first season of the anime came
out reading and seeing once again the
small
humble beginnings of attack on titan as
the fresh-faced training corpse are
faced with a second invasion from the
colossal and armored titan climaxing and
the epic atlas moment from aaron
plugging the hole in wall rose and
giving humanity their first ever win
against the titans was
awesome and this arc one that many no
longer really talk about
or is at least left in the recesses of
their brain as attack on titan expands
and evolves into world wars and
discussions of genocide
is absolutely magnificent in building
the thematic foundation that attack on
titan
now stands on with some of the most
important character development for
aaron mikasa
and armin individually and as a trio
along with all of the survey core to be
as well as exploring the idea of
overcoming absolute hopelessness
this arc is so important it stakes the
theme that
has always lasted throughout the show
since then of not succumbing to despair
and continuing the battle for the sake
of
if not yourself the world around you
looking back at it now it is so
monumental in establishing our
character's inspirations for fighting
and who they are now and today i'm
breaking down
in my longest video yet the entirety of
the beginning of attack on titan and the
beauty of the battle of tross district
and his aftermath
the tross district arc establishes the
fundamental basis of attack on titan at
the beginning of the show
which is that humanity's on their last
legs
many of the new training corps who you
would expect to be inspired to fight and
defend humanity
are simply in it to live cozy lives
within the walls like jean
to finally be able to escape the front
line i mean
they have a good reason for every titan
that they defeat
30 humans die on average i mean it makes
sense to not want to go out there and
honestly just go to your death hello
there but now that it's been five years
since the first colossal titan attack
people are beginning to escape that fear
live their normal lives
the human race is taking back their
dignity
until of course the return of the
colossal title
once again the same reminder that humans
can do nothing
when faced with such an indomitable foe
and history repeats itself as the
armored titan breaks a hole in walmaria
and to switch to the anime real quick
here the way that the silence
contrasts the sudden shift into battle
music right after is just
absolutely beautiful
the colossal titan appears so quickly
that even the soundtrack doesn't have
time to react we're left in
absolute awe and the new recruits at
this point are naive
they think that they'll be the ones to
counter-attack this time and
this is where the fear begins as they
begin to fight back
the very first titan that they even
encounter eats thomas
takes off aaron's leg and devours the
rest of the squad in front of armin
why do i have to watch my comrades being
eaten is this what i signed up for
and after witnessing aaron's sacrifice
himself for armin
there's nothing left within the blink of
an eye he's
alone five years of training and
sacrifice gone like that to just become
another lost soul the cannons don't kill
titans humans can't kill them either
the naive hope that anyone had they
realized was misplaced
this place hasn't become hell it's
always been hell
they aren't fighting to win they're
fighting until the titans eat them
and all of these lines many of which i
took directly from the manga
clarify that humans are the lowest of
the low right now
and this is seen in all of the corpse
psyche before we get
our first shred of hope
the shifting point in this arc is pix's
speech on top of the wall
and honestly i forgot how great of a
character pixis
is until i've reread this he's the
perfect representation of a man that
understands that humans have no other
options that any shred of hope is needed
to overcome their innate and
inextinguishable fear of titans all of
the core who have gathered underneath
pixis
question whether they can take back
trost who can even seal that hole
they're sending us back in there for
another death sentence
they would all rather run and possibly
die trying than continuing with this
duty
until pixar's rousing call to attention
where he reveals the plan to have aaron
turn into a titan and plug the wall
which of course no one would believe no
one would believe that a human can turn
into a titan
and even if they do the center of the
plan revolves around
aaron becoming a titan which is still
uncertain whether he can even pull that
off
and as they all prepare to leave abandon
this foolish idea something they've been
ready to do since the start
pixis says that anyone who leaves right
now will go
unpunished that anyone who is too afraid
to fight the enemy should leave
but also that anyone who'd want their
parents
siblings and loved ones to feel that
same fear that same hopelessness
should leave with them and it's just an
absolutely beautiful line from pixas
and beautiful writing from isayama it
reminds humanity of why they're fighting
not for their lives not to live cozily
within the walls but
to make sure that the people they love
and the people who can't fight
don't have to suffer that inevitable
pain it's the first glimmer of hope that
not just they've seen but that we as
readers have seen
in this very dark manga so far it's a
deep dive into the human psyche and what
drives us to continue fighting
how we can't necessarily abandon our
fear but
hope can be the one thing that lets us
go on despite it
that's what this arc is all about and
aaron represents that hope
one of the core says how after we see
aaron can't control his power at first
they still can't abandon him
because unlike them mere humans there
isn't anyone who can replace aaron and
what he stands for
honestly at this point you don't even
know if the people saying all these
things believe it themselves
but it's all they can do to keep
themselves together to make themselves
believe it
they sacrifice their air mobility with
odm gear to lure titans away from aaron
leading to countless deaths just so he
can make it all the way
that's what's so human about this first
part of attack on titan
it's simply man vs titan the ultimate
overcoming of the
innate human desire to survive for the
sake of a better future
before aaron regains consciousness he
has a dream he has one obvious reason
for why he would want to go outside of
the walls and to the hell that awaited
them there
because he was born into this world
because humans will always strive to
keep fighting and keep going through any
challenges awaiting them
and again here i have to give credit to
the beautiful ost of attack on titan and
its perfect timing
this moment is just absolutely
magnificent it doesn't matter how
terrifying the world is
it doesn't matter how cruel the world is
and they get that win aaron just like
atlas and the greek myths holds the
world and the future of humanity above
him as he closes that hole in a blaze of
glory
humanity finally has its first victory
but of course too many lives were lost
for them to revel in that glory
this moment establishes how every fight
from now on will be an attack on titan
filled with sacrifice this arc makes
clear that there will be no easy victory
in this series to come forth
with all the death that went for this
one victory was it worth it
as they burn the remains of their
friends who they can no longer even
identify
is this victory is this how it's
supposed to feel
even aaron who won the battle for
everyone who everyone put their lives in
the line for is
chained to a bed after it all has to go
through a trial
there is never gain without loss in
attack on titan something we come to
accept as the battle of trost comes to a
close
it's really important for us readers and
throughout this entire arc
not only other parts i've gone through
so far are really crucial but most of
all it is
absolutely vital in developing our
characters from the start and clearly
defining all their goals
especially armin now i've already made a
video before on why i love armin and why
his character is so important
but i didn't go into an intense amount
of detail into the very
introduction of his character and what
he goes through in trost
more so a broader view of it all so here
i'll dive into the micro of what he goes
through and overcomes in this arc
which is his evolution from being
protected and feeling
worthless to finding his own value and
moving past this self-loathing
along with what i was saying earlier
once armin enters the fight and
immediately his entire squad is eaten it
reinforces his own thoughts of himself
as worthless
as always being defended by others and
never being able to act
himself but that all changes when his
moment comes and where he defends aaron
to the rest of the core
and pleads to them to let him survive
when aaron and mikasa give armin the
final call on what they should do
when he realizes that the friends he had
always depended on and felt like he
wasn't equal to
reminded him that they have never
thought of him in that way
this is the first and in my opinion the
best moment to show
the kind of bond that these three
characters have
one that inherently relies on
co-dependence and trusting each other
more than anyone else in the world
aaron and mikasa would have died here if
it weren't for armin
likewise when armin has to wake aaron up
in his titan form to carry the rock
this arc would have ended an absolute
failure if armin weren't there
if he didn't remind aaron of what they
were all fighting for and it's this
shift of him becoming more confident in
himself
and helping his friends that is so
inspiring and great for his character
check out my video on armin if you want
to hear more about why i love his arc
and growth and speaking of these three
characters
another important aspect of this arc is
making clear what mikasa and aaron's
bond is
the relationship between mikasa and
aaron is very complex
something that manga readers i'm sure
can agree with now that the series has
ended
mikasa ever since she was saved by aaron
as kids has essentially acted as his
protector
we see their mother entrusts this role
to her as she's dying
and begs mikasa to take aaron away who
she knows would never leave
she is always there to keep him in check
whether he says something stupid or
fights with
jean or whatever but we also see the
other side of it in mikasa's utter
dependence on him as the only home she
has left
she talks about how as long as aaron is
around she can do anything
which is rather naive and pretty
simple-minded up until the conclusion of
this arc mikasa very rarely takes her
own life's value into consideration
but of course just like armin this
changes when she realizes that aaron
died but decides that she'll continue to
live on
even if it is only to remember him we
see her now as an
individual character but one who of
course still prioritizes aaron
even if she isn't relying on him now her
life is still devoted to him
they almost have this competition
between one another to see who can
sacrifice more for the other
who can defend the other the most they
will essentially
always be one another's pillar which
makes me kind of feel bad for armin for
third wheeling but you know he gets his
own growth this arc so it's okay
it's the kind of bond that will continue
not just until death
but even beyond it
i think jean and reiner are the two
other side characters who received the
most development during this arc
which shouldn't really be surprising as
both of them are some kind of parallel
with aaron
jon is similarly headstrong to aaron but
realistic
and reiner is another tragic character
with a similar story to aaron and in the
future actually acts as his rival
as we see now but let's focus on jon
first
jean's attitude starts off as solely
wanting to rank high in the training
course so he can live comfortably in the
military police
which is of course understandable as i
was talking about earlier the world up
to this point is filled with despair
humanity has never won against the
titans who continue to corner them
further and further within the walls
he even says himself how he is the one
more so than anyone else that's
looking at reality jean embodies the
helplessness that humanity feels
and isayama kind of uses him as a
scapegoat at first
he's purposely meant to seem like that
pessimistic and annoying character
because he doesn't really understand
what hope is
but of course that changes very quickly
and that change
is a result of marco an old but
hopefully not forgotten character
now a lot of marco's depth is actually
cut from the anime so here i'm talking
mainly about the manga
marco is described as a natural leader
by aaron
in a test where you kill fake titans to
gain points and increase your standing
within the training core
something that you need to be able to
join the military corps and have a nice
life honestly
marco instead acted to attract the
titan's attention something he
acknowledges as pointless in this kind
of test
and then jon is immediately confronted
with the sad truth that marco was killed
in the battle for tross
unknown to anyone of course now we know
what happened but we didn't then
it was just another testament to the
worthlessness of a human life
in our eyes and in the characters that
such an important and inspiring person
can disappear
just like that without anyone
remembering and then we get to the scene
where they're burning the corpses and
jean decides to join the core
he has an obligation to marco who was
erased from history because he was at
the wrong place and at the wrong time
to guide others as marco would have
wanted him to
jean's difficult decision to join the
survey corps to not resign himself to
his weakness but use it to guide others
is beautiful the scene as everyone
stands in front of jean in front of the
burning remains of their allies
saying that he will continue on so that
they don't end up like that
it's the ultimate triumph of a
pessimistic human growing up
which is what again this arc is really
all about
[Music]
and when reiner is first introduced here
during their time as training core he
connects with aaron over their absolute
determination in their goal
aaron in killing all titans and reiner
in returning home
unlike armin and burt holtz who are also
part of the conversation
these two very purposeful and
charismatic characters really take the
spotlight
i mean it's just such a great
conversation as well seeing the
parallelism between aaron and armin and
burt holt and reiner
after of course knowing all of their
backstories
reiner doesn't necessarily experience
too much growth in this arc but his
added presence in aaron's life
is very important reiner as someone who
is versed in the pain of being a soldier
of not meeting expectations and having
to move on despite
losses like with marcel makes him the
only one who aaron can really take
advice from here
it just establishes this really crucial
dynamic between them
one where they both feed off each
other's strengths and see themselves in
each other
it's really interesting to compare how
they first met to how they are now in
the anime
which actually brings up my last point
which is the foreshadowing
[Music]
of course as you all know there are a
lot of foreshadowing moments at the
beginning of attack on titan
like isayama knew what he was doing from
the start
reiner's immediate reaction to hearing
aaron transform into with titan and
seeing the smoke
all of the panels of him annie and
birdhole together all of it
is great but there were two moments that
really stood out to me personally
the first being a single line that was
said when the core were ready to execute
aaron for being a titan
where the man says no man can prove that
he's not a devil
which of course has huge implications
now in the discussions of racism against
eldians and subjects of emir in the
anime
it was just a really interesting point
that everyone thinks this way not just
marlians even aldians when faced with a
titan think exactly like that
all humans are innately the same and the
second and most important part of this
arc in my opinion
was the discussion between pixas and
aaron above walmaria
and this part of the video does have
manga spoilers guys so i'm sorry if
you're this far in your anime only but
this part is absolutely vital to
understanding the finale of the series
and is one of if not the biggest moments
of foreshadowing
in all of attack on titan so you might
want to skip
or actually just stop watching the video
probably i don't have anything after
this part
if you don't want any spoilers but
anyway pixis talks about before titans
existed when humans were constantly in
conflict with one another
over disputes and ideologies and this is
where he says a theory
if a powerful non-human enemy appeared
humanity would probably unite and stop
fighting itself and what eren says in
response
is that that's pretty rosy it's dull
it's unrealistic which initially
surprised me looking back at it now
considering that aaron is essentially
doing that at the end of the story
but thinking about it a bit more it made
perfect sense
he says that even now in the trost arc
when titans
corner humanity and they all have one
common foe
humans are still far from united
but he also says that if they don't come
together soon continuing to fight will
be too much for them
aaron has always known from this moment
that becoming the single enemy to
humankind won't be the end of all things
and during the finale of the series he
acknowledges that he must entrust the
rest to armin
and the core to find the solution
because he's always known it wouldn't be
as perfect as pulling a lelouch
if you don't know what that means watch
this video
i just thought that this was really
interesting and just another tribute to
isoyama always knowing how he would
craft this story from the start
and that is my full review of the
beginning of attack on titan and trost
district arc
and why it is absolutely incredible
tell me if you guys like these longer
analyses of specific arcs or just parts
of attack on titan and i'll be sure to
pump out more in the future if so
you